state of decay Aaron Sampson didn't this
game already come out it did now it's
out again but with fewer penis textures
alright state of decay a year one
survival Edition I don't know what Aaron
is talking about with the penises but
you did just run over a zombie they
tried to attack you're wrong he tried to
get on my track and I wasn't having it
so yeah state of decay year when
survival edition on Xbox 360 also a PC I
believe Xbox one you mean Xbox one it
was on Xbox 360 now it's on Xbox one yes
you get a discount if you previously
owned it I think it's like 33 percent
cool so like is does that mean this game
is 66 percent the only 33 percent the
same stuff what's new so this is the
whole game of state of decay plus uh-huh
plus DLC the one the DLC I'm playing
right now is lifeline so there were two
DLCs lifeline is the military one it was
really cool actually so state of decay
the original one you're a survivor
during the zombie apocalypse you don't
know what was happening until you sort
of stumble out of your weekend retreat
uh-huh and discover the world has ended
lifeline is these exact opposite you
start as the military he's basically
trying to contain the zombie apocalypse
by going shopping at a grocery store
well we're trying to basically a strat
extracts scientists all right other high
valued members of society oh man I value
members of your face getting chomped up
oh oh alright so the zombies are coming
at you and you've got a golf club now is
it it was my understanding the original
state of decay was a lot about like not
necessarily fighting zombies but just
kind of like just trying to track some
my best friend yeah just trying to
survive and you're not like trying to
kill all the zombies you're trying to
accomplish other goals and survive
uh-huh by like gathering resources
fortifying you the place you're staying
in etc but in lifeline this is the
military one are you that was good
vehicles are your best friend are you
like more powerful is that can you like
take on more zombies or you know you
still have to be careful
yeah so the cool thing about lifeline is
that you like I said is the opposite of
the original state of decay so in
lifeline you start with a lot of
high-grade military gear and you get
whittled down as opposed to the original
one where you start with nothing and
work your way up home god dude it's a
bad scene yeah you gotta get your friend
oh and I was trying to you but this is
all infected
okay so huh just for starters and state
of decay this is a game that does kind
of respect your decision making in the
sense that it gives you enough rope to
hang yourself with so you need to
actually plan out you know when you
leave your base every time what supplies
you're gonna need to survive I recommend
three packs of medicine a sturdy melee
weapon probably don't need to because
you probably won't go through two in one
mission will Parker on the back coming
through the back entrance well I need to
run all these zombies over so I can
actually get in there without a screamer
um I'm trying to rescue somebody that's
why yeah just go in the back and I could
do that but that's fun is it is there
even a batter is super infected I
probably need to call in some help
okay so there's actually a lot more
things you can call it in lifeline to
there's a couple of cool additions as
you're the military yeah you're the
military sources in the original state
of decay you could meet up with the
military and call in certain things
let's see
but so that's calling really want bonus
survivors Preppers packs cool so let's
call them some snipers what the hell is
a Preppers pack that is a part of this
DLC it actually drops like a cool car
and some awesome weapons let's see if we
can do it by the way if you demolish
your car you're kind of in trouble when
they do drop it
the roads near you are too crowded I'm
gonna have to get to position all right
well let's go figure out where our go
he's not he was there a minute ago
maybe he died died so that's cool thing
about this game - it's got permadeath so
this is just an infestation you don't
want to be near one of those you do you
want to clear them out if you have the
right weapons uh so let's like those
snipers that you had yep there is a
zombie you can call this sniper just
killed the zombie that was right up on
you yeah check it out though so you've
got I think they have eight or nine
shots all right
let's equip my let's see both survivor
stuff job posts actually if we
established Nano on your car isn't it
messed up yes so that's that's a cool
thing about this game is it respects
your intelligence if you drive a car in
somewhere and that car gets demolished
like you're your quick escape might be
whoa okay so that guy you don't want to
run into him because he will explode on
your car and mess up your day it just
looks like a naked dude with a pillow in
front of this groans a high-level pillow
crack zombie who explodes in acid all
right real good yeah we got to clear out
the Screamers the Screamers are the
problem here but there's actually two
infestations I know you can stand in
front of a broken gate and hold why to
repair it yeah so there's a lot going on
in state of decay how long does it take
like when you fire it up till I get
you're just sort of get in to figure out
what's going on get your head around it
and get comfortable with what's going on
the biggest adjustment is the game
starts off as a third-person zombie
action game and then it turns into a
base management simulator where you're
juggling multiple characters you're not
always playing with the same character
yeah that's the biggest adjustment all
right hey this ain't happening let's get
out of here oh I got a police car do
this you're switching vehicles yeah I
guess your truck was pretty messed up
you know what else as cool as they added
in
they had that actually does something
that actually lures them of course it
does man get out of there this game
actually added trunk space which is
really cool so where you used to have to
basically go around and make multiple
runs to the same location to clear it
out you can actually put the larger
packs in the trunk of your car now this
is stuff that you're picking up or stuff
that you're bringing with you to the
location stuff that you're scavenging
then bringing back to base this the
resources that you need to basically
build up your base okay cool so this
like I said it turns into a base
building simulator after a while yeah
let's go back out and see what missions
are going on I'm driving way up oh no he
is still alive we were trying to rescue
this man but he's stranded in between
two freaking giant infestations and
those are dangerous those are old
yeah pretty dangerous you know the rest
of this game is scavenging and surviving
and building up your base you need
resources to do that and you need to
scavenge places to get those resources
is that is that kind of loop the same in
lifeline when you're starting as
military versus the sort of vanilla
state of decay when you're you know
playing as a survivor it's a little bit
easier in lifeline to begin with but you
have to be careful because you're
steadily running out of resources over
time so you can get kind of cocky
because you think you have all these
great weapons and then you basically
start getting whittled down so would you
start if you were to pick up state of
decay year one edition having not played
it at all before would you start with
just normal state of decay or would you
start with lifeline or would you start
with the other one well it depends what
you oh let me see if I can do this
yeah clearing out the old Tartan mark
yeah whoa you were getting shot real bad
dude oh you may witness perma death this
is not a good scene that was a special
zombie yeah it it jumped on you oh no
that wasn't a person a policeman clearly
making bad decisions in this game right
now you see Muriel are
go back in your police need car race car
alright time to get out of here does
this game actually teach you how to
hotwire a car cuz that seems like the
most valuable skill one can have in a
zombie apocalypse get out of here get
off my car do you just have to like rub
them off or can you press a button to
open up your door your door you can door
them off nice all right let's get back
to base the characters had a bad day
we're gonna switch to another character
with a different set of weapons we're
just gonna just just try that one again
yeah well I mean can you drive that
energy drink truck you can drive some of
the energy drink trucks in this game
they've taken too much more whimsical
approach to the world although the
mechanics are still brutal as ever
there's a lot of just kind of like
hilarious trucks such as the piggy
towing truck excuse me what it's like it
it was a joke in the first game
You've goodbye these billboards it said
piggy towing and like a pig yeah it's
just like a cheesy tow truck company
nice they put those trucks in this game
so you can drive them now the tow hook
is just a useless wiggle it is it
actually is that's the thing nice
vehicles are also faster because the
Xbox one has more power behind it
they've allowed the people the draw
distance is quicker and so they've
actually put in cool vehicles yeah I can
recall the technical performance is an
issue that state of decay has struggled
with in its in various incarnations is
that correct yeah I mean this is a game
that you play for the mechanics if
you're playing it for you know technical
mastery I gotta be honest the 1080
upgrade I'm not that impressed with it
it's okay graphically and this game is
you know it's plenty buggy but at the
same time what I love about this game is
not has nothing to do with how it looks
it's just this like awesome zombie
sandbox simulator with base management
where you're juggling multiple
characters who can all die that's kind
of the amazing part about this game
what's the end game for lifeline or for
state of decay the
state of decay you were trying to escape
Trumbull Valley uh-huh let's call in
this pack and see what happens by the
way your bass is not safe like you have
to establish a safe area of operation
around your base so for example I put
this outpost up I need to probably clear
out this and put up another base and
then you can mine another a post and you
can mine the whole area oh wow
but for example here is your this is
your base right now oh my goodness has
so many things going on in these menus
yeah so I don't have enough resources to
set traps or maybe I've already set them
you know it's yeah when I played state
of decay like we need to build let's put
in I don't know how let's put in some
toilets so I can put in a generator
that's smart so we're gonna put our get
it yeah just go poop out behind the wall
we need we need power should we put in
two eyelets I mean this all this base
building mechanics determines how safe
your base is and whether characters
recover and like all just all kinds of
things
uh-huh you you absolutely cannot ignore
it all right let's see if this happens
Preppers back get me a prepper is back
yeah when I was playing state of decay
it was definitely crowded you know it I
could see yeah I didn't get much past
the original this sort of starting area
at the hunting lodge but it could
immediately see sort of how this game
blossoms into something quite complex
and we've had a lot we have a lot of
fans of it in the office
I guess so the question is you know with
one of these sort of re-releases well
are like deluxe edition kind of releases
is who is this worth it for you know
you've got people who've never played
you got people who played some of state
of decay people who have maybe wow like
it's played a bunch of state of decay
but not the downloadable stuff and what
do you think if you haven't plays life
oh no car not another one of those guys
yeah guys nasty wow this dude is just
get off me
oh are so fast he's a special zombie oh
nice - hunch get in the garden in the
car the nice thing is that the cars are
just like your best weapon in this game
area ii special zombie a park on you
okay so i want to set up a quick outpost
over here and make my base a little bit
better protected i'm just in case they
have a lot of funny names around here -
you like boobs boobs
let me see if i can call on the members
back you know you really want this
preppers pack i do
and it's part of the xbox one dlc
primers back i gonna let me call it in
come on purpose let me call it come on
bear oh not happening give it up a bit
dream is dead and you're not able to
prep back yet alright well go take it
out to one more location you are driving
recklessly I'm just gonna just kind of
killing zombies right there for your
vehicle man okay go to someplace crazy
and let's do something and then you'll
die and be sad and what everyone will
enjoy this stream okay we show people
permadeath good plan
perma death is kind of nuts I don't know
man I don't want to totally mess up your
situation last time we're gonna try it
one more time see if they let's do it
two minutes oh that's not gonna happen
oh he just break and they go flying off
that's good okay here we go
mission this person just wants to lose
where you want to live where are you it
was Aereo's and not a giant infected
area investigate artillery that sounds
cool no that's not the same thing but
who cares
artillery I mean yeah artillery sounds
good oh there's that draw distance
showing us how those buildings are
messed up yeah for some reason like I
said it was a jump this game is not
technically - ah oh no I'm sorry there's
a switch to that here switch to the head
truck or something hell doorbell ditch
you can actually ditch while you're
driving but that seems under that you oh
you got those sweets
what are those side exhausts yeah this
whole game is unsafe that's what I say
you can when you start the original game
um you could you know play it for a
couple hours and then your first base
gets overrun you realize you're playing
the game all
and the wise thing to do is is just
start over again start over yeah hope
that went well
off-road yeah here we go it's cool
I don't think and get in that Oh Steve
weaken the power of a tidal wave that I
know can those buyers look flat yeah
it's not drivable all rights go
investigate the Attilio site and then we
get to it our killer eyes the bone shack
pick up an MPC alright here we go
that is the kind of truck I feel like
you'd want to drive in the zombie
apocalypse yep there's a friendly Wow
just getting real mauled yep
for a second there I almost thought he
was eating the zombie hey what's up
Vince you have I first I thought that
was a machete - you're wielding but it
looks like a scimitar I think it is I
think it is indeed a scimitar all right
clear out some Zed's take this on
so is this you may look like the combat
system is pretty much you're just
hammering on the X button here and then
when they go down you hold a button to
execute which builds up one one of your
meters so now basically you're just
defending this spot and then you'll get
some artillery and for some reason there
is a picture of a baby on the screen
that is a distraction device that is one
of the many tools in your arsenal to get
away a baby you just throw down a
literal baby don't show yeah and you're
like hey guys here's a baby they're
there they're juicy and small and yep
everybody line up that's good right
there good job that was good
all right oh yeah that was a good
maneuver all right cars the best weapon
you've got you're gonna activate the
baby yeah I can I don't wanna waste your
baby maybe these are valuable currency
hey what do you want me to do here a
bees are prized in many what do you want
from me game ok search you just have to
kill as I said the nothing life or it
says artillery sight clear nothing left
I see something zombie right there
alright although this mission was go
the artillery site and see if there's
anything there and there was actually
nothing there
I mean that make sense in the apoptosis
totally makes sense it's not usually the
way that video games roll but that's
that state of decay have disappointment
you can have disappointment in state of
decay your one survival it wants me to
go there though alright let me show you
how the baby works alright usually not
getting killed you throw a baby to the
zombies what Oh mortar marker is that a
dance baby rego here we go are these I
call in a mortar strike okay this is
gonna happen watch this uh Oh No
they ran away from the baby too soon
it's all gone wrong Vince
save yourself no let's see here Aaron
all you have to do is shoot Vince in the
leg and then they'll just devour him you
can get away Vince
eat him well that's a state of decay
you're one survival addition on Xbox one
and PC Aaron and Vince are gonna try to
not die horribly but yeah if you guys
haven't enjoyed the state of decay now
you can also enjoy it anything else
Aaron Sampson state of kay I really like
this game if you've already played it
consider this edition three particularly
if you haven't played the DLC cuz I
really like it a lot cool thanks for
watching everyone catch you later yeah
you